[Music]
i think everyone has an origin story
that matters and that's important
for me my origin story began at the age
of seven years old as i laid in the
hospital fighting septicemia which
potentially could have been a terminal
illness i discovered a comic book based
on my love for a fictitious character
batman and in that comic book there was
a character named dr lucius fox he was a
black man he was an engineer he was a
financier the ceo of wayne enterprises
and he made all the gadgets for batman i
read as much as i could about lucious
fox desperately clinging to all the
narratives that exposed his brilliance
in both engineering and making things
but also strategy and building bridges
and community with the chief of police
and the journalist and so he was the
prototypical mentor that i needed at
that moment to see all of my gifts and
talents in one person now while he
didn't actually exist in real life i
gave myself a mission to become him
growing up on the south side of chicago
it's quite difficult i didn't fit in
i often was laughed at for my dreams and
aspirations because it's unheard of to
say hey i'm a nine-year-old child i want
to design gadgets for superheroes people
really believe that you're just
pretending but i was serious about my
mission and my intent
as i matriculated through primary school
and to secondary school and into college
what i realized is that it didn't matter
what people thought about my dream it
only mattered what i thought about my
dreams so i stopped seeking validation
and acceptance from others
i stopped seeking a yes and i started to
eliminate the way people can tell me no
multiply that times my inquisitiveness
and my creativity and i ended up being
nike's first black design intern in 2001
that came from a traditional art and
design background when i left nike to
come to stanford i was a senior designer
i was the youngest person to reach that
title at the time when i held it so
getting to stanford was just honestly it
seems like the natural outcome for my
journey but at the time as i was going
through looking at schools looking at
different environments it definitely was
something that i felt was the highest
aspiration for me to strive for as a
creative
upon arrival at stanford gsb you know i
quite honestly was searching for
a community of like-minded individuals
who saw my talent as not being something
that was integrated vertically into a
corporation but something that can
transform the way we engage with society
the way we have difficult conversations
the way we design for belonging design
is the filter you use to get to the most
ubiquitous outcome that helps the most
amount of people and so our job isn't to
provide solutions most people think it's
drawing pictures producing products it's
really to ask the boldest questions to
move humanity forward
and so i don't think we can move forward
anymore in this attention-based economy
without taking design seriously not just
letting us have a seat at the table
letting us be the head of the table
design the table source the table
because we have skill sets that are
valuable to really move humanity forward
and move each of these antiquated
industries forward we need to try new
styles of leadership we need to
radically shake up what it means to be a
ceo what it means to be a founder the
look and feel of what it means to be a
board member if you're at the gsb if
you're black latino lgbtq woman atheist
muslim christian whatever it is that you
identify as you are welcomed and you are
accepted and you are needed and that is
the thing you have to understand there's
a difference between being wanted for
your skill set and needed to be part of
the texture of a community we have to
radically challenge the status quo and
we have to do that with love compassion
and the willingness to sacrifice some of
our opportunities for the betterment of
the collective that is what it means to
be a servant leader and that is what we
were taught at stanford
so i've often been asked
you know did i become lucious fox
in my mind i did in my mind i've
dedicated my life to using my gifts and
talents to serve others i wake up daily
and i have a practice of asking myself
how can i kill my ego today i put myself
in situations where
i serve often i reach out to people you
know through text messages and voice
messages and ask them how can i be there
for you and i think that's the
embodiment of the spirit of lucious fox
he didn't have super powers he was super
compassionate he was intelligent he used
that to help people who were out
fighting the world's greatest issues and
challenges
so
simply put i believe i am becoming a
lucious fox and it'll always be in
motion because there'll always be
problems for me to try to solve and
there'll always be challenges that can
be met with love there'll always be you
know people who feel left out that i can
advocate for and speak up for so that's
the mission of a person like lucius is
to never feel satisfied with the work
because the work isn't done until all of
us feel loved and feel seen
i'm jason maden i'm a designer i'm an
entrepreneur i'm a gsb alum but most
importantly i am a father and i am a
husband
you